a
[Música]
sicilia batió un récord histórico nada
agradable al registrar la temperatura
más alta en la historia de europa en la
región de siracusa donde los termómetros
alcanzaron los 48.8 grados centígrados
la semana pasada el instituto de
ciencias atmosféricas y de clima de
italia que registra datos desde 1800
calificó el verano de 2021 como el más
caluroso en la historia de sicilia el
cambio climático y el anticiclón
africano lucifer hicieron que durante el
ferragosto esto si quiere decir el fin
de semana del 14 a 15 de agosto se
registrarán temperaturas superiores a
los 40 grados en casi toda la isla
el gobierno regional decretó el estado
de calamidad y solicitó al gobierno
central el estado de emergencia los
bomberos sicilianos tuvieron que
combatir más de 30 incendios durante lo
que va de este verano para completar
casi una decena de personas fueron
detenidas por causar algunos de estos
incendios de hecho un agricultor en
catania perdió la vida tratando de
combatir uno de estos
[Música]
españa acaba de vivir una ola de calor
de las más intensas de su historia la
semana pasada se han batidos récords de
temperatura con una máxima de más de 47
grados es la prueba del impacto del
cambio climático españa padecerá grandes
transformaciones en 30 años en madrid
las temperaturas serán igual de
calurosas que en marrakech y en
andalucía córdoba será como bagdad un
tercio de españa ya sufre de una tasa de
certificación muy alta pero a lo largo
de este siglo más de los tres cuartos
del país podrían transformarse en
desierto según la agencia europea del
medio ambiente la península ibérica'
será la zona de europa donde aumentarán
más los episodios de sequía otras zonas
sufrirán las consecuencias de la subida
del nivel del mar playas del sur podrían
desaparecer
inversiones millonarias serán necesarias
para construir infraestructuras que
permitan evitar catástrofes naturales
ah
turquía está viviendo un verano de
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos y tras
dos semanas de lucha intensa contra los
peores incendios en décadas ahora unas
inundaciones han arrasado el norte del
país dejando 80 muertos mientras que
continúa la búsqueda de 30 desaparecidos
las lluvias torrenciales han afectado
tres provincias en el norte del país y
han dejado poblaciones enteras anegadas
al desbordarse al cauce de varios ríos
el agua ha destrozado casas carreteras y
puentes dejando aisladas a más de 2.000
personas que han sido rescatadas con
helicópteros y lanchas varios expertos
apuntan que aunque es cierto que este
año ha llovido más de lo normal y en
algunas localidades se han registrado
más de 200 litros por metro cuadrado ha
sido la especulación inmobiliaria la
principal causa de estos destrozos a
construir poblaciones enteras encima de
valles y ríos
[Música]